[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde
nous sommes aujourd'hui au nom ça
commence déjà tu testes aux réflexes des
médecins pour le réflexe atavique tu
jouer s'amuser et jouer les oies
aujourd'hui nous dans tout le monde pour
un concept très rigolo tous un grand
chapeau max max max sa franche la poudre
si votre ami prend vous poubelle en
disant ça ferait un beau chapeau
changeais d'amis on n'a rien inventé
c'est un concept qui nous vient tout
droit de la chaîne et match yann bello
là c'est lauren qui a découvert sa et en
voyant la vidéo j'ai lu tous envie de
faire la même avec ces gens ici parce
qu'on se connaît très très bien dans la
vraie vie chacun a son style
vestimentaire typique qu'on va jouer en
deux équipes de deux je serai avec
maxence lorraine sera avec seb
le but est extrêmement simple chaque
équipe va devoir s'habille comme une
personne de l'autre équipe
j'ai extrêmement va expliquer cette
vidéo moi je vais devoir tout faire pour
à l'issue de cette journée ressembler
lorraine et lorraine va tout faire pour
me ressembler à moi est pareil maxence
tu adores devenir la mecque sens il fait
la gueule brian nous allons devoir nous
fournir vêtements accessoires maquillage
ok on va aller se fournir en vêtements
dans des friperies à paris ce qui
simplifie la chose pour toi de me
supporter ou est-ce que vous êtes prêts
à partir tout de suite en direction des
friperies et acheter tout ce qu'il faut
on sourit on se revoit que en fin de
journée quand vous serez aiguisé et là
ce sera le reveal la découverte si vous
avez fait pour de ressembler on se
confie
j'ai vraiment leur seul dans les rênes
du shopping avec les caméras et j'en
rêve qui se réalise un gros en analyse
adducteurs alors déjà niveau des
fringues c'est pas fou tu peux rejoindre
m et george gillet en tee-shirt et un
jean coupe droite
ouais et c'est bon tu en es une cassette
pour mes cheveux mais après c'est plus
niveau déjà du make-up donc fausse barbe
en france où elle est à toi je vais me
refaire tout cette épreuve mais qu'il
faut qu'on se concentre sur tous les
petits détails lors elle met des
pantalons éléphants c'est ou en bas ça
fait ça wepad f tus à moi mon propos
n'est pas de danger pour kate a pas de
baisse elle fait le même trait
d'eyeliner au millimètre près avec
chaque jour je pense en eau elle met
très souvent des trucs à fleurs à
regarde voilà tu vois ce genre de trip
leur wii la wii se souvenir c'est ça
regarde une deuxième creux des trucs à
fleurs mais donc ça il faut il faut
vraiment pas que je me vois avec sa voix
aux accents vrai je vous parle avec un
avantage de fous du mormon ping aux
endroits où on va et puis des endroits
où lui sami al attiyah davantage assure
maxence accorde une importance dont vous
aux chaussettes
il amène à 10000 avec des trucs
différents succès qui met des salopettes
je vais bien mais en vrai je suis bien
trop quoi champions faire ça c'est
tricher mais ça fera gagner des points
je pense c'est totalement fou mais ça ne
sais quoi par exemple des balles une
lunette et portraits sous mes casquettes
et très souvent il a un sac à dos tu à
chaque fois je croise il un sac à dos
ils ne portent comme ça est très souvent
il a une bouteille à la main oui c'est
vrai ils parlent pas c'est là que ça va
la fin o'keefe et sport et en même temps
qui fait normal direz et pantalons
pareil mais quand rien de bien sorcier
avoir à me soucier
on est devant kg shop nous allons
acheter tout le nécessaire en termes de
fringues pour imiter seb et lorraine
donc on est actuellement dans la
première friperie dit maxence c'est
vraiment il ya max est partout c'est
incroyable j'avoue je suis allé dans une
triperie allons donc mais en france et a
pris feu juste un mec mais c'est
tellement bien c'est trop bougé depuis
pour encourager sa au courage et les
friperies c'est trop bien
[Musique]
maxence est hyper adepte des chemises
il adore les chemises colorées par
exemple ça pour être très maxence chaque
match sa [ __ ] que d'un effet prix donc
il a envie d'acheter pour lui la non
maintenant si j'aimerais bien avec moi
il me faut de la fleur de la flora spot
la tulipe de la rose tu as tout je
trouverai jamais une luxation prend sa
chance à la mecque et de la flore mais
qu un mec ça toi direct c'est bon ça
c'est vraiment ça c'est le rêve
c'est incroyable j'ai ma demie j'évalue
je fais de la merde ya un problème avec
ce vêtement on va le régler et on arrive
moi c'est le pantalon qui est plus dur à
trouver un nom beaucoup trop large aussi
dit oui extrêmement basses et des jeans
sommes donc je mens je vais en train de
dire que l'uqam et des jeans enfants
lorsqu'on prend
mais c'est quoi ce vêtement dans les
regardez regardez comme c'est bizarre il
ya un truc dedans et là il ya un truc
pour l'entregent mai mais du coup fait
pas à logis saint maxence mais ça c'est
pas mal c'est typique les trucs un peu
baba bodi relève rex mais moi je vais
aller je vais aller passer c'est déjà
faire une idée à tous ok c'est hyper
lent et je vais faire un méga rouler ça
passe ça tu vois tu pars sur un truc
comme ça aux mecs ça marche tu veux
redire est un truc comme ça en vrai
c'est pas mal je vois rien que ça c'est
pas mal non mais ça va être hyper sympa
je me demande s'ils s'en sortent
ça fait lucas faut que je fasse
désormais à tours jusqu'à moi vous êtes
luca place est totalement hors et ça le
fait non pas une coupe mais l'accessoire
wii direct quoi ça a été rapide trop
longtemps
ouais c'est du cas des pyramides
ok tu allais au mec t'es bien ben oui
quant aux longues non c'est pas des
joggings ou en jogging un peu tu vois la
viande halal ça mais c'est personnel
ses pattes d'eph je vais pas laisser
pour toi ou alors tu essaies par la
suite à une contre c'est un pad est fort
mais williams est de taille haute j'en
profite pour regarder s'il ya pas de
l'accessoire très très important les
bananes de maxence alors lui il faut de
la banane c'est pas la banane que les
autres
ça c'est une banane maxence et même pas
rechercher plus elle est là elle une
fois une casquette c'est parce que je
vais devoir cacher tout ça ah oui c'est
vrai du tout le thème bah voilà
totalement lucas ça je reconnaissais pas
la tuer quelqu'un sur cette terre c'est
comme on veut un vrai je n'ai jamais su
je suis parisienne ne sais pas combien
d'heures yo tout le monde sait ce coup
ci je pense que casquette et tee-shirt
ou va tenter notre chance c'est dans une
entreprise
bon mais je mets jogging son jeu égal à
80 pourtant johnny tu crois ouais ouais
ouais c'est bon c'est bon allez on y va
on a quand même eu quelques prises moi
ça me rassure
ce qu'il me reste à trouver un débardeur
blanc des chaussures et un sac de la
prochaine friperie fonds sont d'époque
la jatte 2 to maxence
[Musique]
donc là on est devant la deuxième
freewin il nous reste des trucs à
acheter moi j'ai klein jeans donc voilà
ça un peu près des rythmes en quoi pour
moi alors là je trouve que j'ai tout
pour l'enseignement entre les chaussures
on vante les chaussures et moi le tee
shirt et l'acacia donc c'est parti sur
la 2e plus gros stack il aujourd'hui
écran tactile parce que je suis très
heureux on prend la route pour aller là
c'est pas loin on voit un mec tranquille
pas on apprend que sa cote est vraiment
au coeur d'un buzz et mettre au niveau
en ce sens qu'elle allait bien tu me dis
quand on est arrivé à recevoir ses
lacets la scène pas très juste là ouais
ok on y va on va être ya trouvé mais si
vous cherchez un endroit où ne pas vous
aviez comme lucas c'est une friperie
vous trouverez tout ce qu'il ne faut pas
pour lui ressembler
[Musique]
c'est dans les bols un temps cherchent
non plus en fait tous les bugs que
j'étais il faut pour la fin mais en fait
c'est des trucs hyper large soit parce
qu'on est plus max en soit c'est un peu
moins moche mais surtout un pêcheur mais
ça marche
il manque juste les baskets et le sac et
on a filmé et on a fini non bon sens en
opposition on va pas s'éterniser
je ne suis pas mon bonheur qui va
partager dans une pierre de plus simple
ce serait bien qu'on accélère et puis
commencera essayer n'importe quoi pour
faire des vannes du genre des
déguisements ou tu fais semblant d'être
quelqu'un d'autre est d'avoir un autre
métier sur moi dans une fait un malaise
en plus chiant c'est pas parce que j'ai
quasi tous
[Musique]
bon on a assez de ce qui nous vaut mais
qu'on a tous trouvé jetons content on
est de retour
on est dans le studio de bigorneau
coquillages on va faire notre mise en
beauté les accessoires la part une autre
présentation voilà c'est parti pour la
tenue de tables nous avons deux
possibles pantalon le premier un jean
levi's le deuxième mec c'est celui-là
sont pourtant un du gringue à l'ancien
sénat avec 100% ensuite au mix assez la
master pillage à vous déjà oublié ça
c'est vraiment le haut vraiment celle
quoi on l'a trouvée dar es tu là pour la
trouver direct il est là j'ai acheté
deux bateaux une banane chant à la
youtube aussi incroyable j'adore faire
ça
et sinon ya celle-ci ensuite un bob 51
anisette un oui ma faible en fait parce
que c'était un beau sauf qu'il est bien
trop court et le deuxième qui est un
alfa romeo bon fossiles mais un peu
moins et qui est encore pire rien dire
elle aussi un dessin avec un chat un
film avec un chacun au chapeau comme sa
gestion est le moins pire c'est un truc
de feu d'artifice je pense que c'est
celui sur lequel je vais partir parce
que c'est juste le mois pierre on a
trouvé dans le style de maxence je pense
ici parfum que celle ci correspond
entièrement à ce qu'il pourrait porter
dit rien et je suis prêt à parier
maintenant qui va dire quand je peux la
prendre à la fin de ce tournoi on est
sans cesse à maxence avant tout un look
avant-gardiste un look unique max à ce
genre de lunettes et bien sûr le patron
pièces majeures de sept ans ça fait un
max en soit l'achat il mesure le truc
tout simplement les trucs de lorette
doit mettre les choses sur elle son
chemin mardi
par contre tu fais du 37 ouais mec je
fais tu m'as je suis grande un débardeur
blanc qui descend très bas mais tout
sera caché n'oubliez pas dans le jeans
pattes d'éléphant pattes d'eph drogué au
dessus ça il y aura le vêtement chelou
que personne ne comprend d'ailleurs ce
que les gens vous dire vous êtes trop
con c'est évident ça marche comme ça
bref ça c'est bien lorraine juste
répondant et le jeans pattes d'eph et la
boulaye vu tout à l'heure le cac charge
et wej hâte de voir surtout nous avons
pour commencer une casquette parce que
j'ai devoir cacher mes cheveux donc bon
je retrouve un méchoui xterra méo à
casquette il emmenait souvent alors on a
après un t-shirt franchement le hall de
l'udc est hyper rapide pas parce qu'il
ya un tee-shirt noir
ainsi basique et pour finir et ça vous
l'avez vu vous l'avez vu quand je
l'essayé dans les tripes c'est le djing
tennis beaucoup aux accessoires ouais
moi j' ai vous allez voir g par
l'accessoire de façon à faire là la mise
en beauté comme on dit et vous allez
voir c'est ça va tout changer
on va changer ok ok mais qu on s'habille
ces partis sont en bas c'est par six
mois je crois attention transformation
un peu de poids impressionnant n'est-ce
pas je suis max vois le truc c'est que
j'ai encore tout à fait je fais tout il
faut juste y retourner après j'ai juste
à sauter comme ça et c'est bon c'est lui
car il va détester processus a été
entamé ce passe plus pour l'un de nous
deux pour le moment nous allons je suis
baiser nuit un pizzaïolo serveurs gérés
par des raids de tablier bon bah je
passe il ya grand chose à dire pour le
moment ou jamais de la deuxième couche
c'est parti bon alors c'est parti pour
les accessoires
donc j'ai déjà un accessoire changer
beaucoup
ouais c'est bling bling de ou fin et
j'ai des bagues aussi à m donc c'est le
genre de bach qu'il a donc cédé bague
argentées comme ça ok on imagine la
laddh sors de chez toi tu vas acheter
ton pas et là sur le même trottoir
quelqu'un arrive vers toi et c'est moi
walikale e lauren à ça va tu penses que
ça je sais pas moi je sais on fait juste
on voit de las vegas parano ou accélérer
ces exactions mais sans l'avoir désiré
mon petit mais qu'est ce qu'on va
commencer avec la la barbe d'une action
ce qu'on va faire sur scène
qu'est-ce que je deviens et tu fais
surtout le tour juste pour faire une
délimitation tu vois juste pour théo la
cote mais non métropole et après on fera
des fera des poils tu supposes bas je
fais des gros sourcils là devant ça
marche à la france à être que j'ai fait
mais chez maxence ou co prend la parole
je viens de me souvenir d'un ustensile
qui s'appelle l'époque je la mets comme
ça c'est un peu mieux
moi je vais vous dire une épingle et je
passe d'un 2 sur 10 à 8 sur 10
on est prêt ces sources mais sur ces
supports je rêvais de me faire une
fausse barbe comme ça vraiment ils
doivent être en train de faire nous on
est trop calme et tout son être eu un
bon mois mais ces ouais je suis sûr
qu'on va faire bien ouej sujets qui font
n'importe quoi
salut c'est lauren et c'est ben oui
c'est ça bloque frites regardez va
perdre jamais cru que j'étais en train
d'analyser leurs barbes un jour on
dirait vie je vais manger du nutella
n'importe comment pour je dirais juste
que je suis passé un marchand c'est la
moustache c'est ça que j'ai oublié qui
me perturbe est ok c'est bon mais julie
sur la moustache on attend je t'avais
pas regardé depuis tout à l'heure mais
on dirait vraiment que j'ai la main avec
un homme et une femme à barbe
tj bon maxence est parti se raser les
créoles aller ça fait longtemps je
prenais deux oreilles mais j'ai les
oreilles percées donc je peux en mettre
on va en profiter bon je vais vous dire
un truc quand on va mettre la perruque
ça va tout sublimé d'un coup on va
apprécier mon déguisement à sa vraie
valeur
vous allez voir mon dieu se trouveront
foule fait troublant l'interview de
prophète on dirait pas l'uqam on dirait
un autre mec qui est battu angers face à
moi de l'eye liner aux mecs ça va être
chaud elle fait un tri tout le monde la
paupière au dessus et elle finit par un
petit picketty sur le côté
c'est vraiment très dur et il est pas
déjà grave je suis là en vrai regardez
regardez regardez la progression avant
après avant après il ya une progression
à tanger des ciels et des lunettes de
soleil ouah c'est vraiment le but on
voit qu'on montre en marche le cas je ne
sais pas me raser sont coupées c'est
vrai je sais pas tout rouge avec ensuite
son d'être au téléphone ouais bah ouais
bah écoutes je me suis plus encore
ouais je crois pas t'en fais pas ça on
attend peut-être mettre en dessous il a
des cernes
ouais tu voyais bien plus le bas des
yeux qui dort jamais et ça m occuper ça
quand on est un tueur à la base et c'est
à moi là bas peut elle mais qu'attend
elle est restée près très près par an
c'est comme ça à temps
bon je fais là ça marche pas du tout
mais mes hommes et d'aucune aide lapin
et forme avec twilight violent que j'aie
jure 112 tu rigoles
je te jure au mec c'est vrai je le
ressens que de nous mais je vous jure
semblait vraiment qu'on pense reprendre
sa marche ou d'un retour on y compte
heureusement ça chauffe
ok maintenant on fait un cosmonaute
c'est celui qui n'a là on sait pas on
sait ce qu a fondé donc je suis touché
le casque de daft punk da funk ou pas
est-ce que tu ferais d'étagés au cern
elle en a beaucoup je les fais tu me les
fesses avec sas avec lequel tu fais ça
tu veux redire ça c'est un bon ouais
mais ça va pas trop me gênait moi ça me
gêne de m'adapter ailleurs ça fait mal
lors de soins avec grange et une peau
sensible
c'est une peau mixte tendance sensible à
rougeurs arrête mec ça mec j'appuie à
peine mais tu fais doucement gros le
toit mais doucement avec meet apic mec
je te montre regard mec ça ça marche
enfin tu t'expliques bien fais le toi
c'est pour beaucoup plus raffinée tu et
à toi même conscience de ta douleur et
bien là c'est exagéré mais c'est drôle
ça mène à leur tour 7 permet pas ce que
tu fais là
mais si jamais je jure que si je marche
vite et où je passe en est ce que est ce
que je monte là la master pièce un peu
de mon costume à montereau leur place à
la pièce la pièce majeure la pièce
secrète
mesdames et messieurs je vous présente
ma tu souffles et ça c'est gagné
mais ces dames il est maintenant temps
du moment tant attendu par vous mais
surtout pas trop changer ça y est de
capter le truc hyper drôle le cap des
trucs verdon et du truc j'adore ces
scènes je suis toujours content quand la
lorraine c'est comme ça toujours comme
ça et tout le temps comme ça oui c'est
vrai dans ma santé oms à winston
viennent nous donner le logo ils sont
prêts on est prêts on y va oh là là
c'est parti la découverte
allez vas-y sa fille
[Musique]
je suis en stress les gars se serait ok
on y va soit 2 5 m e si troublant est
mêlé à temps les atouts elle restait un
truc de ouf c'est prouvé un est laminée
bayal à gênés on a les bacs en dessous
duquel le petit sac sur le côté ciel
mais termine tout drôle c'est tout est
vrai mais ça trop dur j'ai dû faire tout
seul et le maquillage est jamais fait de
mal et c'est bizarre j'ai l'impression
c'est dans les films nous avons des
échanges de corps oui c'est un peu ça le
fait qu'ils tiennent ses bretelles
tu t'es vraiment rageant c'est qu'on
appelle là là elle s'est coupée trois
fois mais hier vient enseigner et où
j'étais mort de m
franchement c'est césar bien dans mes
cours compte tenu de la popote essayer
si celle où et quand les amis je suis
pas peu fier de cette vidéo parce que si
on est passé par toutes les émotions
l'annoncé barrette seul connard étonné
moi je suis à venir éroder parce que
c'est peut-être que je fais du rap je
suis ok sur ce je voulais c'était un pur
des gros scoops et bien ce jeune ce que
tu vois là la vision qu'ils étaient amis
ont de toi en fait j'ai pas si léger
mais faut comprendre le délire mais je
me souviens je m'attendais pas à vivre
un truc comme ça j'en reste aux robes
battant ya un miroir c'est moi mais
bizarre un peu quand même c'est trop
stressant c'est génial moi je suis
troublé mais en fait on voit que son
bloc tous sur certains détails tu vas et
ça constitue la vision globale de la
personne qu'on a c'est trop drôle mais
jamais fait qu'alain qu'alain maxime rey
a déjà retiré qu'est ce qui a fait dire
j'écris si l'accord du dakar c'est ce
qu'elle va super bien
ma chérie abonne toi à toutes les
chaînes ici et à bientôt dans une vision
d'espoir que ça vous a plu
au revoir à l'hégémonie là dessus natsu
go 4 go mais sans hâte sous tutelle donc
à bien des deux nouvelles vidéos on se
retrouve bientôt
[Musique]